♪♪
.
>> JESSE: BIG GOVERNMENT ISN'T
BACKING DOWN FROM SNOOPING ON
YOUR BANK ACCOUNT.
AFTER A FIRESTORM OF CONTROVERSY
WITH A NEW PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE BANKS TO INFORM
GOVERNMENT ABOUT ACCOUNTS MAKING
TRANSACTIONS OVER MORE THAN
$600.
SECRETARY TREASURE TRYING TO
CONVINCE AMERICANS THAT THAT
REALLY ISN'T SPYING.
>> DOES THIS MEAN THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS TRYING TO PEEK
INTO OUR POCKETBOOKS IF YOU WANT
TO LOOK AT $600 TRANSACTIONS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE PROPOSAL INVOLVES NO
REPORTING OF INDIVIDUAL
TRANSACTIONS.
WE HAVE A TAX GAP THAT, OVER THE
NEXT DECADE, IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
$7 TRILLION, NAMELY A SHORTFALL
IN THE AMOUNT THAT THE IRS IS
COLLECTING DUE TO A FAILURE OF
INDIVIDUALS TO REPORT THE INCOME
THAT THEY'VE EARNED: .
>> JESSE: BUT DON'T WORRY, NANCY
PELOSI SAYS THE CONTROVERSIAL
PROVISION WOULD REMAIN IN THE
DEMOCRATS RECONCILIATION BILL
DESPITE A LOT OF PUBLIC
CONCERNS.
REMEMBER, JUDGE, WHEN THEY TOLD
US, NO, THE FBI IS NOT GOING TO
BE SPYING AND LISTENING TO
PEOPLE?
NEXT THING YOU KNOW THEY ABUSE
EVERY LAW, SPY AND THEN LEAP.
>>.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHO WAS IT IN
CONGRESS THAT SAID THE NSA
DOESN'T SPY ON US AND THEN TO
THE LEFT SAID NOT WITNESSINGLY.
I HATE WHEN PEOPLE LIE TO
MOVEMENT I ACTUALLY WROTE A BOOK
CALLED DON'T LIE TO ME.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH JANET
YELLEN.
SHE SAYS IT INVOLVES NO
REPORTING OF INDIVIDUAL
TRANSACTIONS.
WE ARE NOT SPYING BUT THERE'S A
SHORTFALL, A TAX GAP, A FAILURE
OF SOME TO REPORT INCOME.
THERE IS A TAX FRAUD.
SO WE'RE GOING TO REQUIRE BANKS
TO REPORT EVERY CUSTOMER
TRANSACTION OVER 600.
SHE IS LYING TO YOU.
THEY ARE SPYING ON YOU, $600 OR
MORE.
NOW THE BANK IS NOW AN AGENT OF
THE IRS ON.
>> JESSE: AND THAT'S THE POINT
GERALDO, YOU CAN'T HAVE THE BANK
DEP TEASED BY THE IF HE SAID TO
SNOOP ON AMERICAN CITIZENS
>> Geraldo: WELL, WE HAVE THAT
NOW.
>> JESSE:.
>> JESSE: NOT THIS
>> Geraldo: MY POINT IS, THE
BANKS HAVE BEEN EMPOWERED AND
REQUIRED TO REPORT TRANSACTIONS
OF $10,000 OR MORE.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF DOPE DEALERS, YOU
KNOW, ALL THE CASH BUSINESS.
SO YOU GET YOUR STACK OF CASH,
YOU WRITE A CHECK, YOU'RE
LAUNDERING THE MONEY, THE BANKS
CAN SEE THAT.
>> JESSE: THAT'S A LOT DIFFERENT
THAN $600
>> Geraldo: IT'S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
MANY PEOPLE DON'T LET THEIR
SPOUSE LOOK AT THEIR CHECKBOOK.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Geraldo: AND TO HAVE THE IRS
AND THE BANK -- NOT ME, MY WIFE
CONTROLS ALL OUR FINANCES.
>> JESSE: SHE COULDS?
>> Geraldo: YEAH.
>> JESSE: THAT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA
GERALDO, ESPECIALLY WITH YOUR
FINANCES
>> Geraldo: AT MY AGE
>> Jesse: DANA, YELLEN DOESN'T
HAVE GREAT PR RIGHT NOW.
THEY PUT HER OUT THERE AND TRIED
THE MAKE THIS THING LOOK OKAY
AND SHE DIDN'T DO A VERY GOOD
JOB.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING IS, I
BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL DROP THIS
PROVISION.
>> JESSE: I DO TOO.
>> Dana: BEFORE THEY PASS IT SO
THEY'RE TAKING ON THIS WATER AND
NEGATIVE PRESS FOR NO REASON
REALLY IN THE END.
HOWEVER, HOWEVER, YOU KNOW WHO
THIS IS REALLY AFFECTING?
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO USE VENMO.
>> YEAH.
>>. RIGHT?
>> I DIDN'T THINK OF THAT.
>> Dana: AND BABY SITTERS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT, ALL OF A
SUDDEN, WAIT, OH, BECAUSE IT'S
INCOME.
IF WE WERE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT
DEALING WITH THE ISSUE OF WHAT
JANET YELLEN IS SAYING THAT
PEOPLE UNDERPAY WE WOULD DO A
FLAT INCOME TAX OR NATIONAL
RETAIL SALES TAX AND END THE
INCOME TAX ALL TOGETHER AND THAT
WOULD BE MUCH MORE FAIR IT'S
JUST HARD FOR PEOPLE TO GET THIS
IN THEIR HEADS AND IF ANYTHING'S
HARD YOU DON'T DO IT IN
WASHINGTON.
>> JESSE: VENMO I DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT THAT GREG.
>> Greg: THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT JESSE.
WE COULD SPEND ALL DAY.
THAT COULD BE A SPECIAL THINKS
JESSE DIDN'T THINK ABOUT.
>> JESSE: ON FOX NATION.
>> Greg: YES
>> Geraldo: WE GOT ROOM.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE SOHO GALLERY
GOT A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS IN
PPP TO SHOW HUNTER'S PAINTINGS,
RIGHT?
YOU CAN -- THAT'S TAXPAYER MONEY
THAT WENT TO THAT GALLERY.
BUT IT'S THE TAXPAYERS THAT ARE
GETTING TARGETED AND HUNTER IS
NOT.
THAT SHOULD MAKE YOUR BLOOD
BOIL.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT SHE DIDN'T
DENY IT.
SHE SAYS IT'S NOT HAPPENING BUT
THEN SHE GOES THE REASON WE'RE
TRACKING -- SHE GIVES YOU THE
REASON.
IT'S A SHORTFALL.
SHE GOES, THE REASON -- THAT'S
NOT I DENIAL.
I AM ROBBING YOU BECAUSE I'M
BROKE.
NO, YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO SAY I'M
NOT ROBBING YOU.
BUT YOU DIDN'T.
SO SHE ADMITS IT'S A POWER GRAB.
AND ALL OF THESE PEOPLE, TYRUS
SAID THIS LIKE A COUPLE NIGHTS
AGO ON THE SHOW, IT IS ABOUT THE
WAITRESSES, THE BARTENDERERS,
THE SMALL BUSINESSES.
THAT MONEY'S NOT GOING INTO THE
BANK.
IT'S GOING TO GO RIGHT BACK INTO
THE MATTRESS, 1-800 MATTRESS,
THE NEW BANK.
COFFEE CAN BURIED IN THE
BACKYARD, THAT'S WHAT I DO DANA
WITH MONEY AND OTHER THINGS.
>> Dana: I WAS GOING TO SAY.
>> Greg: NEVER BEEN A BETTER
TIME TO BUY